hey youtubers is Charlie this week on
Teen Wolf it was a little bit like the
intervention episodes of How I Met Your
Mother except it was more like how I met
your beta we did get a nice resolution
to the Scott Liam story but I feel like
the real surprise of the episode was
funny Derek who knew that Tyler hoechlin
was allowed to be funny on this show
hole any new people if you're finding me
for the first time I do weekly team old
videos be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'm even doing a special Comic Con
giveaway that I'll explain at the end of
this video so I'm just gonna start with
top 5 WTF moments then I'll do my review
and then I'll explain all the comic-con
stuff so careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet I'll
just wait a couple seconds ok everybody
ready here we go number 5 Batman Derek
and sheriff stilinski derek has had so
much more fun this season since getting
his mojo stolen by Kate it's like he's
got this whole new personality that
allows him to be funny
Batman Derek was funny in a meta kind of
way just because it made you think of
sheriff stilinski as Detective Gordon I
feel like they're moms together as well
as with Chris argent and into being
every bit as funny as the more
traditional funny scenes that you see
with like
Malayan Stiles or cure falling down
stairs in slow motion
I mean before this I really didn't think
that Derek was allowed to be this funny
on the show he's like one of the
angriest characters that we've ever met
like for instance whenever they were
chained up in the police station that
was just hilarious
and then there was earlier in the
episode whenever he was laying the SAS
on Peter about the mute not being able
to talk normally someone like hoechlin
would be the lead of a show like it
would be written from his perspective
not Todd Posey's it's an ensemble cast
but Derek is a supporting character so I
feel like in exchange for all the
awesome things that the writers do to
him every year they give him all the
most fortuitous scenes like in exchange
for beating on him they let him be
Batman he totally deserves it too they
turn into pieces taking away his alpha
powers killed almost everyone that he
ever loved and now they taken his true
essence and to all that it looks like
Peter is probably gonna take advantage
of his weakened emotional state and that
whole mojo plot of his but number 4
Peters old habits die hard
definitely a cool guideline to walk away
with him killing that mute was just pure
revenge for the axe to the chest before
Peter Claude is faced off they were
basically gonna question him I'm
surprised that Peter didn't take that
opportunity to throw Derek's joke about
the view talking back in his face but it
really wasn't one of those
laugh-out-loud kind of humor moments so
the line that they did give him as a
walked away super-intense was way better
last season Peters secret goal was
learning the truth about Malia and now
that he's found that out what is his new
secret plan and how does Derek figure
into that I think he's just got
something to do with Derek's stolen mojo
the thing that Kate took from him I'm
wondering if he's gonna try and use that
to get his alpha powers back
Deucalion told them all about absorbing
your betas lifeforce by killing them
so maybe Peters gonna do something like
that he already killed Derek's sister
Lucy to become the Alpha once there's
nothing stopping him from trying again
with Derek or at least once Derek gets
back whatever Cape took from him
I feel like Peter trying to get his
physical powers back is also a good
mirror for him trying to get his money
back but number three Malia versus the
full moon she in styles are probably my
favorite pair on the show right now
they're definitely a lot more fun than
Scott and Kira and they seem a lot
closer to maybe it's just because
they've been through something way more
traumatic than the others have just
because you know they both killed people
and been on the outside of the group for
a big chunk of last year remember how
much the twin said being an Omega sucks
that's kind of what Stiles was last year
Malia's story as it relates to Peter is
still a huge question mark - I'm waiting
for them to follow up on that Stiles is
her anchor right now so I don't think
she'd ever leave him but I do wonder if
Stiles would ever leave the pack to go
with her like if she ever did want to go
away to get to know Peter better if any
of you watch arrow quick spoiler alert
for season two basically the same type
of thing happens whereby one of the
characters learns about a secret father
she had that goes away with him on to
number two Lydia decodes the Deadpool
list so just a quick heads-up there was
a bit of a WTF during the broadcast like
the actual episode messed up the audio
dropped out whenever Lydia was in that
record room and you couldn't hear her
speaking to Mason it came before that
scene with the freaky wall so that was
an intentional MTV's broadcast just
messed up in the audio drop they posted
a corrected clip of that to their
official Teen Wolf website so if you
want to see that scene it's just her
talking to Mason but the Deadpool list
is the whole impetus for the killings
this year it's a huge deal here's a
quick shot of it look at what certain
people are worth it's implied that the
more powerful people are the more you
get paid for killing them so who the
hell is this Carrie Hudson person and
why she worth twice as much as Scott you
know the true alpha and when you look at
the rest of the pack
it just gets super depressing does it
not completely suck that cure is only
worth $6 Derick is only worth 15 Lydia
is only worth 20 Maliha is not on the
list at least that we saw I think that
they just showed us part of the list
though I think the full one is longer
it's like Scott's pack put together is
worth barely what one of the normal
people on the list is worth and I'm
assuming since we haven't met a lot of
them we'll just meet them over the
course of the next several episodes the
benefactor as we learned from werewolf
beard delivery man is paying out
mercenaries to kill supers in Beacon
Hill's quick sidenote - during that
scene we also learned that Liam's
friends are some of those mercenaries
he's not on the list right now but that
doesn't mean that he won't end up on it
and my number one WTF moment Scott gives
Liam in intervention more than anything
the WTF moments in this episode were
funny moments and it was just beautiful
the rapid way this deteriorated from the
bite last episode to the bathtub to the
lake house to running through the woods
it really reminded me of one of those
How I Met Your Mother episodes with the
interventions Liam you have a problem in
case you missed it Scott was basically
quoting Derek throughout the whole
episode Liam we're brothers now the bite
is a gift even Chris argent had to tell
him to just do things his own way like
he completely spaced on the fact that
Derek is a terrible people person so he
was just trying to replicate a terrible
experience that he had liam is still a
giant question mark right now in terms
of character development Scott and Derek
came to blows before turning into BFFs
in season 3 so I wouldn't be surprised
if Liam went a little bit nuts on him
before the end of this season we're also
still owed a big explanation on what was
going on at Liam's last school they
explained that he got kicked out for
smashing up that teacher's car but they
didn't really go into deep as to why he
smashed it up whenever he was explaining
it he said that he wrote it's your fault
on the car and we have no idea what that
means Liam has currently dethroned Derek
though as the angriest character on the
show if you guys have any be sure to
send him a giant wolf sighs chill pill
but now it's your turn let me know in
the comments what was your favorite
moment and what do you think is gonna
happen with Liam becoming Scott's beta
do you think it's gonna be a good thing
or do you think it's just gonna blow up
in everyone's faces and don't forget
this is just the first half of the
season they're gonna be airing season 4b
the trailer for that at Comic Con that's
gonna be like a whole different story
though overall this episode was again my
new
from this season I gave it an a just
because I'm super impressed anytime a
show can continue to build the energy of
a story consistently for so many
episodes usually what you see by now is
someone off episode that just completely
stops the action dead in its tracks
that's why I'm so happy that Teen Wolf
has chosen to be more see relized like
Game of Thrones for instance this
another show it's just where they build
the story in each episode like the
events of the next episode depend on
what happened the week before I love
what they're doing with Derek by making
him like the supernatural Batman of the
season helping sheriff stilinski solve
Deadpool murders we're still learning
about the benefactor and because of the
way they're teasing Liam's friends as
mercenaries and the batman derek thing
kidding the problem from different
angles i think that everyone is gonna
learn who that mystery character is at
the same time it's like you have all
these different scooby-doo teams you
know tackling the problem from different
angles and they're all just gonna meet
in the middle I'm also wondering how
Parrish fits into all this
I love how they've been pairing him with
Lydia so far she did make that comment
she's over dating high school boy so
either that means she's totally gonna
hook up with him or if she's just gonna
spend a lot of time with him all Mulder
or Scully x-files
I don't think Parrish is up to Mulder
levels yet but I do buy Lydia as Scully
I'd say my biggest hanging questions
after this episode are who's the
benefactor and who is that person that's
worth twice as much as everyone else
Carrie Hudson so here's the details on
all the comic-con stuff next week
they're gonna air episode five I'll do a
review for that and that will be the
beginning of my Teen Wolf Comic Con
giveaway I'm gonna be giving away up
Beacon Hill's lacrosse shirt so all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment whenever I post that
video it's just like any of the other
giveaways I do except it's like a
physical item instead of like a gift
card the giveaway is gonna be open until
I post my episode 6 review the week
after that so the giveaway is gonna be
open for like a full week so don't worry
you'll have plenty of time to enter also
here's what's going on with the stuff
actually happening at Comic Con I will
be watching the Teen Wolf panel if you
guys really want me to record it and
upload parts of it just be sure to let
me know I have a poll in the description
be sure to check it out
it just has a list of all the different
panels that you can vote on for me to
upload
I'm just asking everyone you know which
panels they want me to upload most so
that I can prioritize which ones I do
first so in the meantime click here to
get my episode 3 video and
here to get my episode 2 video thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives
[Music]